[Musique]
puisque tu es né de
moi la vie
continuera et tu
[Musique]
découvriras
l'indiérence que veux-tu que je
t'apprenne tes questions seront les
miennes
[Musique]
et tu chercheras ta
vie ta
différence ce sont toujours les
regrets pas les remords qui nous
ronge mais si tu
plonges si tu
PL il y a les montagnes d'amour qui
t'attend
il y a les mains il y a les POS qui se
tendent si tu
plomes si tu
ples tu prendras ton élan vers le ciel
comme l'oiseau quand il déploie ses AES
si tu
ples si tu
[Musique]
pl on te dira qui
aimer on te dira quoi
chanter on te dira où aller pour tenter
ta
chance mais Bala toutes ces
idées ne garde que ce que tu
es ce que tu veux deviens
vrai si tu
avances ce sont toujours les
désirs pas les plaisirs qui nous
rond si tu
plonges si tu
plonges il y a les montagnes d'amour qui
t'attend il y a les mains il y a les
points qui se tend si tu
plonges si tu
PL tu prendras ton élan vers le ciel
comme l'oiseau quand il dépiss ses AES
si tu
plonges si tu
plonges tiens-toi
droit dans les
bras le verti
[Musique]
n'y pense
pas ne regarde pas en
bas regardetoi devant
toi ça
ira si tu y
crois si tu crois en
toi
concentre-toi ne pense
ça fais le vide en
toi allonge tes
bras avance d'un
pas et
[Musique]
pl il y a des montagnes d'amour qui
t'attend il y a des mains il y a des
poins qui se
tendent si tu
plonges si tu
plonges tu peux tout tu peux toucher le
ciel comme oiseau quand il dépoiss ses
air si tu
plomes si tu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ples